all right thanks
do you guys hear that song is pretty
funny right yeah have you heard that
before
all right well this is it here right
it's a love song about statistical
significance all right yeah all right so
if you want to check that out feel free
hit we're pretty saying that the provost
at UVA actually sent this to us pretty
funny
okay uh all right so let me get fired up
here all right so all right I'll try to
make this quick because clearly I'm
between you and the bar which is always
a very dangerous place to be
so I had this philosophy I you know I so
I'll talk about this for a second so
I've been oh good it works all right so
I've developed a few data science
programs I did one at GW and now I'm
down at UVA helping them build programs
and there we have a school of data
science at UVA do you guys know that you
guys do that all right
can't get around the plaza in I feel
like I just asked for a place for myself
is that what does have anyway so I think
it's the first one in the country but as
a result you know we have to I've been
thinking about because we're designing a
lot of programs right and we're saying
to ourselves you know what do we want to
teach what do we want to be in terms of
like the languages we're using these
conversations okay and so there's been
some discussion in terms of location we
just be one language type of school and
I was just totally against that I think
the answer to this question by the way
is yes right and so I've been having a
thought experiment about how I can
communicate that out so I'm gonna try
and do that to you guys because this is
a user friendly group right this is a
target parent group so I'm gonna talk
about this this question right that I
had up here right so really does does
are and really what I mean by are is not
like are the language but are the
community right does it encourage
diversity I think the answer is yes so
let's let's talk about all right so just
so you know when I think about diversity
I think about our a whole bunch of
different ways this might be the least
technical talk all right so the day
sorry about that but it's the end of the
day so maybe that's okay so I think
about diversity I think about it in all
sorts of different ways all right I
don't think about it just as
gender which courtly includes a race but
also like just multicultural background
and then also the domain with which you
come from
okay so data about this is hard to find
so we're gonna try and use and I have
some don't worry I did do some analysis
and I have like an art markdown I'm
gonna show you so when I think about it
I think about kind of that way like how
is domain specific that encourages
diversity alright so so that's part of
the way that we're going to approach it
so this one talks about there's all
sorts of there's also to research that
supports this idea that diversity is
just good for all sorts of ways
including profit and efficiency and all
sorts of all sorts of important things
all right not just for the general use
of it alright so this so these are just
examples of research this is about how
much gender backgrounds make a big
difference right this one here - I think
ok just so you know I did my homework
alright so as a community we need to be
cautious about how we move forward all
right I think this is important to think
about because in a lot of ways it's a
new it's a new field all right we feel
like we're in it all the time we feel
like it's you know it's been around for
a while but it's new and it's still
developing right we're building schools
around it and so this is kind of a bad
graph it talks about kind of the gender
diversity in computer science so we went
up and then all of a sudden it went
really down really quickly alright and
so this is just a highlight of a
highlight of this is from data and I
suppose these slides just for the record
from the Department of Education all
right as well and so these are also some
slides here that talk about again women
in STEM fields it looks like it's doing
owner this work
no all right looks like we're doing
pretty good up there and health related
and life sciences but pretty bad in
computer science and engineering
all right the same here all right this
is a bit this is just general diversity
is we're talking about instant jobs in
general again not what we would tend to
tend to like to see so we have to be
cautious about data side so the question
is where is data science and then I'll
get to the art part about how I think
arc is helping alright now this is from
General Assembly so I said these aren't
you know there's no perfect set of
information here all right but this
talks about kind of gender diversity in
general all right and actually data
science up here this is bad that's not
we want that to be lower
even though data analytics is pretty
good we're just kind of
interesting right okay and over here and
Jen we're looking about just kind of
race general diversity kind of data
science is right in the middle all right
okay so how does our kind of encourage
these types of diversity conversations
or is that is it true that it could do
that all right so I was looking to
explore this all right and and bring it
to this to be me and talk to you guys
about it because I think it's important
all right so where do we go to get
dinner all right we're just good a kegel
okay so that's what I did so I don't
know if you are familiar do you guys
just want to listen to this again or no
all right you let me know all right look
very good and I do think all the
presentations today are basically a
dictation of my inadequacy for this so
I'm sorry about that
they're making me feel insecure okay all
right if you know those who can't do
teach right so here I am alright so
anyway so so there's these two really
big Kegel data sets all right from 2017
a 2018 that that is a survey it's like a
date assign survey have you guys seen
this survey have you seen it okay all
right so all right first point of order
all right it's definitely biased
yessir so it's clearly not a perfect
representation of the data science
community it's a representation that
people go to the use Cagle but which
maybe is okay all right so they did two
of them they're pretty big one was one
was 16,000 responses and other was
23,000 and so I did a bunch of data
manipulation and stacked them on top of
each other there's a really nice package
called stack I don't know if you guys do
you guys know that package stack hey
there you go so I gave you so stack
actually just it takes these two data
frames and stack them right on top of
each other it's just one way to do it if
you want to do something outside at the
apply are are tidy verse which is kind
of taking over so we ended up with like
40,000 answers and I reduced it it down
to just these kind of these three or
four variables here gender majority
major all right I had to brief Edwige
factor level major okay so I put it into
these big buckets also there's a whole
bunch of missing and I did this at like
I think a lot of I did this at like
12:30 in the morning last night so I'm
sorry about that so I didn't take out
the missing values but there's a whole
bunch of missing so I apologize for that
but anyway so these are the big majors
and then as we kind of move down we can
see the percentages associated with the
different languages or these are counts
associated with the languages alright
so Python way up at the top right so
python is is very high we see are in
terms of people responding is it's not
14000 its 4,600 okay but in general we
know that right that there's there's a
big larger base because it has more of a
larger utility not utility but you know
for people that are using it more for
different purposes okay and so this is a
graph across so these are different
language usages and so again what I'm
thinking about here and just to clarify
it is that is that it's because are in
large part and I think this is true
through my experience it comes from as a
tendency to come from social sciences
statistics people are using into that
space and those fields in general have a
tendency to be more diverse across the
board especially gender wise alright so
here as we can see from computers like
here we see that a large proportion of
what's going on inside computer science
is Python related right and I think
other people did this similar analysis
online and this is a bit hard to tell
but as we kind of move up into social
sciences right and arts and humanities
and in math and stats the balance
between Python and R has a tenancy to be
a little bit more even okay as compared
to down here and and with this is pretty
much all Python and then ours
represented slightly less alright and
these are people that come from those
domains so this becomes a little bit
more clear when we come down here and we
just look at the percentages okay so I
was surprised by this one but again this
the data sample there is pretty small
but if we look across social sciences
all right
in terms of our and Python uses it's all
I mean it's not perfectly even but it's
pretty close right and received pretty
big disparities when we look at computer
science which is above it right okay or
just below in terms of usage here okay
now keep that in mind when we referred
back to the gender diversity insight
computer science so it looks like here
you know this is a good thing all right
all right that make sense all right
so alright okay so here's some more
statistics right associated with this
alright is that this is commit store
github in terms of and a lot of this
information is about gender diversity in
general but I think about it it broader
than that alright so you can see are
here alright and this is information
from this article here
you can see that the contributions for
female contributors to ours is pretty
high I mean it's in general this is all
this is all female contributors but our
is by far the highest one here alright I
mean it's still small in general but it
is higher alright okay
and so let's stop and these are things
like I said you guys are probably
familiar with these you probably know it
right but I think that when we think
about the our community and the reason
that it is so good or we need to be make
sure to support it and basically I'm
making it I know I'm talking to it you
know everybody on that same page here
but you know these are points all right
there's infrastructure all right there's
a foundation and this comes from that
same article right and that the our
communities are very connected and
particularly the strength of the our
ladies community I think makes a big
difference and so when I think of all
these things even though I think in
general when we think about like how
what the overall usage of the different
languages okay you can think of our is
kind of like a market enforcer that has
a tendency to create good behavior
across the community all right so it's
like these have you guys seen that maybe
this is a bad reference but there's like
a documentary on beer wars have you guys
seen that and they talk about how the
micro brews make a difference like
they're actually creating good behavior
in the larger beer larger beer market
right they have to provide more variety
that might be a terrible analogy I'm
sorry about that but I do think that
because of the the power base for our
right that the strong community
all right the natural tendency towards
diversity and then the tendency of it to
be more in social sciences where there's
more diversity in general it makes it a
really big positive market driver for
the data science field in general right
I know you guys are like you know we're
all there I'm there with you too RR is
definitely my favorite language but I
also think it's important for reasons
just outside the usability I think it
hasn't build the kind of impact good
behavior across data science as the
field begins to mature okay does that
mean does that make sense okay all right
okay so there are other cool things to
hear if you don't know about this the
our foundation task force all right
so for under for women and
underrepresented minorities right so
that's a taskforce that they're looking
to encourage and facilitate ways to
encourage more women of color and and
gender diversity to be in the art
community all right so that's a very
cool thing that's going on if you don't
know and then here's the last thing all
right these are different ways that you
can potentially continue and I'm gonna
give you guys some time back here to
continue to contribute you guys already
know this already but if it makes you
you know be more passionate about the
art community then that's great
alright so continue to support it
there's an article here all right that
shows ways that you can get grants if
you're looking for that type of thing to
actually encourage diversity and data
science so there's some statistical or
some structured ways that you can
actually seek funding to help build that
and then you know a lot of us here are
educators all right and we're building
programs and so I'm doing this
consciously too so I think it is
important we're kind of laying the
foundation for how we move forward all
right so be thinking about and I'd like
to get I think I'm preaching to the
choir here but build our to your
programs and or at least think about
different ways to give options that's
all I got eight minutes back all right
okay thanks